نحن في هذه الاثناء في منطقه الحساينه غرب
مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه حيث اغرت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه خلال
الساعات الماضيه على هذه المنازل الامنه
والشعبيه بطبيعه الحال لعائله الرواغ
والمنازل المحاذيه لعائله الرواغ قاعدين
نتفرج على الشاشه بنتابع اخبار لا هو ديب
لا هي زلين مزلين لي هوايه صارخين في 16
واياد بعتو له صاروخه لعنده واحد 16 قطعهم
كليتهم 11 شهيد ببح هقت لسه في تحت تحت
الانقاظ مليان شهداء قديش ضليت تحت
الانقاظ ثلاث ساعات ثلاث ساعات ضلينا تحت
الانقاظ عم جونا وقعدوا يخبطوا اما جان
الدفاع المدني كنت نايمين اسمع قبيسي قش
في حدا نرجع قال لا مرو زي الهبل كلهم ين
وكلهم 200 وكلهم
جداد 15 نفر ض على ايش ايش ذنبهم ماه مش
دخل في حماس و دخل في حاجه حرام عليهم ولا
الدول العربيه كلها تقف معه ل وين احنا
بدافع الاقصى ط الاقصى للكل مش
لب ما زالت هنا العائله وجيران هذا المنزل
يحاولون الوصول لمزيد من العالقين تحت
الانقاظ كما يتحدثون ويقولوا بان هناك
مازال مفقودين جراء هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه الكبيره والعنيفه بثلاثه
صواريخ من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائ
هذه المنطقه تحولت بشكل كامل الى كومه من
الركام والدمار الكبير الذي لحق بها حسب
ما شاهدنا وتشاهدون في هذه الصور من داخل
المنزل الذي دمرته الطائرات الاسرائيليه
احنا مهجرين من الشمال هجرونا اليهود
وجينا هان قصفنا برضه في دارنا مش مشكله
جينا هان فيشي اسبوع اسبوعين لهم ضربونا
كمان مره كلنا اطفال هان فش كبار فش اطفال
والله كلنا اطفال عمد كان هان قاعد واولاد
نزل صحفي نزل الصاروخ في نصه اه وابنه
متصاوب الثاني في
مصر هناك اضرار كبيره في محيط المنزل من
المنازل المجاوره للغار الاسرائيليه على
هذه المنطقه في منطقه الحساينه غرب مخيم
النصيرات سبق هذه الغاره هناك غارات ايضا
اخرى في منطقه الزوايده بالاضافه الى شرق
مخيم البريج حث الطائرات الح اسراليه
تواصل غاراتها الكفيفه على وسط قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات الماضيه وهذا ما رفع اعداد
الشهداء والمصابين الذين يصلون لمستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح اشرف ابو عمره
لقناه الجزيره غرب مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع
غزه